welcome everyone
my name is marina marina gandlin i work
in tabula for almost four years
and i'm a team lead in the algo group
in the data science uh group in taboola
and today what i'm going to do is show
you a little trick
we use almost all the time
in our production systems and what i'm
going to talk about today is a little
bit simplified from
what it really looks like in our
production system but uh hopefully
you'll get the gist
and i think we're ready to start
okay so me
already mentioned it but i think i'll go
over it again
this time in english so what do we do in
taboola
so even if you have never heard of us
you must have seen us before
because taboola today is
on probably the world's the world's
biggest publishers
we can see a list of them here nbc aol
the bbc bloomberg and we're on these
pages because
we are curating items to be displayed on
these pages
in a personalized manner what does that
mean
um usually at the bottom or at the
middle of the pages that you open when
you open bloomberg or ynet
you see some items like images and
titles
uh under the title mo for you or
recommended for you or you might be
interested in
and these are items that we place there
live in production and again
personalized for you
so for publishers the service we do
is we put related articles from these
publishers
in their network so that they can enjoy
more engagement
and more user time on their website
and we also put in sponsored items which
is
advertisements and the publishers use
the money
made from these advertisements to keep
their website going on and open
outside of subscription walls so
for advertisers like any place where you
see advertisements
we help grow their crowd and bring new
traffic to their websites
and for users we allow you to have a
better more personalized
sense of more personalized
environment to read on your favorite
websites and we even do this
outside of the publishers you read we
also have a product called taboola news
which is much like google now or apple
news where we aggregate items from
different publishers we work with to
give you a personalized feed every day
so if if my first explanation wasn't
enough what we do here is
very very large scale recommendation
systems
and what do i mean by large scale
think of the moment where you click ynet
coil
on your on your browser and
just imagine that this url request goes
to a tabula
server and what it brings back before
the page is loaded
is a bunch of items that are
personalized for you to read
some of them are from ynet some of them
are ads
and we get that request about
half a million times every second okay
from from bloomberg from ynet from the
bbc
from a bunch of publishers and we have
to give back
a list of items in the time frame of 20
milliseconds
okay so this is the this is the
production beast that we're in charge of
and for a recommendation system what we
have to do is give recommendations
for about one and a half billion people
monthly
billion users unique users monthly and
what we have to choose from is about 10
million items
every month and as you can imagine we
have
something like a hundred thousand new
items every day new articles from all
the publishers in all the languages we
work in
so very very large scale the commander
systems what we call
taboola scale and to face this very very
challenging problem
uh we have our magical algo uh group
which is today 55 data scientists in
israel
about 20 more in taiwan and in la
and we process to solve this we process
a hundred terabytes daily and
and we design deep learning models to
help us face this question
and then we distribute them in taboola
data centers
over in over 20 000 dockers
with models so this is really a
production beast
and we try to get better at it every day
because better accommodations means
a better experience for you and more uh
allowance for our publishers so
this is the scene so let's start okay
any questions
okay cool so
advertisers what do they want uh and who
are they
so tabula advertisers are very very very
diverse
from shuffle to other websites
and car agencies and game developers and
when they put an
ad on a publisher when they pay somebody
to show an ad
they basically want different things and
it really depends on
what you're advertising so if you're uh
if you're a website what you really want
is
more traffic new traffic subscriptions
if you're a car agency
you want to sell more cars have people
purchase cars
and if you're a game developer what you
really want is for them to install it on
their phone
and so one of the things we predict in
taboola and specifically
in my team is whether a certain user is
going to
have some kind of engagement after he
clicks on an ad
so what we're really trying to figure
out whether there's going to be
something post-click or not so one
or zero and hopefully that clicks
because this is a classification problem
right we have a user
reading some kind of article in y-net at
two o'clock uh
in the afternoon and i'm showing him an
ad about cars
is he going to click and is he going to
purchase a car
after he clicks so how do we rank
easy we have an online prediction
machine
and when you guys type ynite.co.il
request goes from your computer to a
tabula server
and it has inside some user features
like the time whether you're on desktop
on mobile things like that
and the context features like what are
you reading what's the title of the
webpage you're trying to open
and on our servers we have a list of
candidate
at number one number two at number three
and we take their ad features right the
title of the ad
who's the advertiser what's the image
and we send it to one single dl model
deep learning model and that deep
learning model
outputs a probability
for some post-click engagement okay
so i want you guys to remember that this
is a single model because
it's easier that way
what we do we shuffle the ads we get
according to their post click
probability
and we show the top k results and when
you scroll down you're going to see the
first and then the second and then the
third one
okay so how do we train a model that
does
such a thing uh easy
everything is easy we build a data set
and
basically each row is a request right
the same request we talked about earlier
with the context feature the user
features and the ad features
and our label our our target
is whether we had some kind of
post-click uh engagement
or we did it like zero or one
and one thing we need to notice here is
that the post click types are very very
different right we talked about what the
user what the advertiser wants
some of these post click are app
installs and some of these post clicks
are car purchases okay um
um i hope you guys understand that
some roads some types of post-click
conversions
are we see more often than than others
right
so app installs we see a lot and car
purchases
not as many so we looked at the model
and uh yeah the accuracy is pretty good
it's online
and everything looks fine but then we
decided to drill a little bit deeper
and see that for app installs we're
really doing
really well like the we look at the the
rock the aucd score
and it's really really nice but when we
look at the car purchases
our ability to classify whether
somebody's going to buy a car or not
is really not not that good much less
than what we do for app installs
and it's pretty easy to figure out why
right
the majority of our data comes from this
category
so the weights we learn are fitted for
this case
and not so much for the car purchases so
what do we do we have a data set
and it's highly skewed what can we do
so option number one would be to
downsample right
easy i just take a small amount of my
app installs and i try to build a model
that's balanced i have the same amount
of app installs as i have for car
purchases
so what could be wrong with that
small data set yeah it's a very very
small data set and instead of making
the car purchases better i made the app
installs worse
so not good so the opposite of
downsampling is data augmentation
augmentation
i can take my car purchases rows and i
can duplicate them
i can maybe do some fancy uh
um noising on them and
i i might get a somewhat up sampling
yeah
okay so i meant if if anybody is
confused by this term i meant
up sampling okay um i will get
more rows but i'm not sure i'm going to
get a better model because i don't know
if these rows are just
they represent something real like real
requests that happen in the real world
world
another option is to weigh the loss
right this is a
like a classical suggestion if 80 of my
data set
is population a i can uh
downway the loss for these rows
and put a higher weight on the
population i want to stricken
straight strengthen so we were sure this
is
this is gonna work we tried a lot a lot
a lot of weights a lot of functions
and this always failed um
and then we started thinking maybe we
should just do two separate models
so i present solution number one
two different models i'm gonna split the
data set
the top pros are gonna be just rows that
have app installed conversions
and their negative counterparts and the
bottom
data set is going to be just car
purchases and their negative
counterparts
so what's wrong with this solution ah i
have
like this is a very simplified uh
architecture which i'm going to use a
lot during this talk
so it's basically features that go into
dense nets that's layers
a lot of them they output a logit and if
i put that logic in a sigmoid i get the
probability for a post click
ok so let's get back to what is wrong
with two different models
so a lot of things are wrong um
just like with the down sampling i
basically get one very very small data
set so if i want to
train a very large model on it it's just
going to be bad
and with the second point is if i train
two models and i output two scores
comparing them like i did when i want to
rank
is actually not a good idea if they're
not calibrated pretty well
this is like a calibration model a
calibration problem
it means i need to train two different
uh
models which is not that heavy on the
pipeline if i only have two
but if i have a large amount that's
that's pretty bad
and then serving is
is a it's pretty much a nightmare
because instead of sending all the ads
to
one single model that outputs one single
score for each
i need to route route each advertisement
to a different model
and then bind their scores and some of
them have different running
running times uh it's really a bad idea
in production
and the worst of all and this is like a
major part
when i split the data sets i get no
generalization
right our models are supposed to learn a
lot of things not only about the ad
about the user and about the interaction
in with the context
but these two models are gonna need to
learn it separately
with no co-learning between them
so i get the specialization i wanted but
i don't get
any generalization so booze
okay so that brings us to solution
number two
and our inspiration here was something
that's called a two-headed model
raise your hand if you're familiar with
the concept heard of it
okay what like multitask learning
exactly
multitask learning so what is a
two-headed model
i put my features into one single model
i have some dense layers that are shared
but then i have some dense layers that
are split between two tasks
usually there are different tasks um
and it's calculated simultaneously so a
popular use for this architecture is
probably
inputting an image and i have one head
that classifies whether this is a dog or
a cat
and the other had a head
returns the the bounding box okay so two
different outputs from a single input
so this sounds like a good idea right we
get the generalization we wanted we get
the specific
specification we wanted but it doesn't
really fit what we're trying to solve
here right i don't have two different
tasks i just want
one number to be outputted
but we tried it anyway so this is the
two-headed model that fits the
problem i described earlier we have
some dense layers that are shared
we have some dense layers that are split
and i output two numbers
and i just pick the one that fits me i
look at the features
i know which conversion which post click
action i'm looking for
and i just pick one of them for the for
the loss
so in training i only take one to
calculate the loss with
um and if if i do this uh
in prediction in in production uh i need
to choose one
so it's a little more complicated but
not that bad
right i can deal with choosing one score
from a lot of scores
but we wanted something different that
makes it
a little bit easier so it's basically
one more tweak and that's it
so we call this the gated two-headed
model
and it starts off exactly the same
like our previous slides but
it includes the choice of which logit
which output i take inside the model
okay so i build in two gates
that's either zero or one and if the top
one
is one the other one is zero and
the formula for the gate for the top one
is
it's going to be one if the conversion
is an app install
and otherwise it's gonna be zero okay
so if that was too quick we also have an
example
so imagine a request comes in and it's
an advertiser
that develops a game and we know the
post click
we're looking for is an app install so
the top gate becomes one
the bottom gate becomes zero when i do
the forward propagation
i stop here because i multiply the
output by zero
and what i get outside is the logit for
the up install
nice and easy when i do the back
propagation
the top specialized weights get trained
they get the gradients through them and
and so does these weights but those one
those ones only get trained where we are
where we have rows that are app
installed
okay i'm going to do it again for car
purchase
when we train when we forward propagate
the bot the top gate is going to be zero
the bottom gate is going to be one
and the output is going to be the logit
for the car purchase
the reason using it if the
app won't be installed there's no point
of talking about the
car purchase so
the the advertiser the advertisement is
for an app yeah so basically the app
that
won't be downloaded it's
speaking about we don't care about the
probability for a car purchase on
an ad for for an app well
okay so what do we get with this final
very nice and easy architecture we get
generalization at the weights that are
shared
we get specialization with the weights
that have degrees of freedom
for a special type of post click and we
get a single output
which means we can send all the ads
through one
model in production and not over
complicate stuff
so one model to rule them all geeky joke
here
so this is super useful like um
the the history of this thing is that we
really we we
really did discover it on a very similar
scenario to here
but then once we have this architecture
we are using it in a bunch of places
and it's like a poor's man's version of
a mixture of experts if you guys know
the google
paper so it works on any kind
of heterogeneous data set like
if you can bucket your data set rows
into
not that high not that high amount of
categories i would say 10
15 works fine depending on the size of
your data set
and we have now a bunch of different use
cases for it
sometimes we use it to mix different
geos like if i'm
using a model to learn something about
ads in the english language
but i think that ads in the different in
the english language are
kind of different between uh english
speaking countries
like australia and new zealand so we use
this
and then we figured out that we actually
don't need anything to be different we
can just use it as an ensemble learning
and we just randomly go on the top
branch for the odd request and the
and the bottom branch for the even
requests and that works
nice like an exam ensemble learning with
the same set
so that's it so the final takeaways here
is that we have a nice model that's very
simple to implement that does both
generalization
very well look just as well as the early
version of this model
but it only but it also gives us some
specializations for our
minority uh populations in the data set
uh it fits perfectly into our production
schema because uh it's a single model
and it outputs just a single score for
each ad
and of course we we demonstrated here
for two but it works perfectly for
ends i would say up to 15
depending on the the size of the the net
so yay um
do i have time for questions
um so i'm trying to understand the
difference between the last
two new models you present just in the
background
that is done for both sort of
pieces so with the the difference is the
the single output that's the it's just a
tiny tweak but it makes a lot of sense
in our production
and it means calculating the loss
doesn't need any other trick
because if you would implement it
manually you would need to choose one
and then
calculate the loss only on it it's very
similar to multi-class
classification if you in salah
and but they're very similar like
there's no architectural
insight between two and three it's just
easier in production
yeah when you said you're you're using
it for up to
15 so you went
one category with 15 different plus or
but let's say like in this case you had
like a
two population one from two different
countries
and also you had the different uh
category where it's either uh our per
or uh app installed so how do you
combine so we don't we don't we
just imagine you have one column in your
data set that has
say eight categories and we build it for
that one we don't
combine languages and ad types with the
same
we might be able to but we don't do it
uh for now
we just do it on one category to pick
one
categorical variable where you can split
it yes
and how do you pick which one is the
best so it depends who
do we want not to be unfair for
okay so like you can imagine that
advertisers that
advertise cars they they're willing to
pay a lot
for putting their ad on their website so
we want to make sure we're fair towards
them so they'll continue to advertise
do you have some college score
um i'm not sure what is the quality
score
but not only
yes but this is irrelevant
a loss function
so this is a question unrelated so
it's a good production question but
unrelated to this lecture
yeah you said it takes uh 10 15
categories
we haven't tried did we try ribbon
specific use cases when you really want
to make a difference between two
populations
but otherwise there is a memory uh
so ruben says do not try this with more
than 15 categories
maybe you can try the iphone network
for the things you want
if i cluster them and then i have 15
buckets
you can train a network it gives you a
network
that doesn't
[Music]
sorry so you asked about the shuffling
yeah we we output candidates with a
random order
and we want to shuffle them we want to
sort them sorry
sort them according to the score they
get outputted from the model
yeah so from the top scroll to the
yeah did i say shuffle i meant sort i
meant sort
yeah that's a good
will so does it improve the calibration
meaning
the two populations get similar
calibrations
when you use the gated model
yeah better a better calibration that
would be the best
you said that each ad gets a single
score
but how do you know to which category it
belongs you also need the output of the
gate
when you run it in production so that we
we control the gates according
it's one of the features the the action
type
so we can you saw the um the formula for
the gate was
one if app installed so it's a it's a
feature
whether something is like the type of
the post click
so it's it's true we needed to have one
more arrow
to the gate from the features if i think
that's what you meant
it's it's easier in production so our
system is built for a model that takes
features and
outputs one score so if i output two
score
it means that i need to do some not very
sophisticated things
just to choose one of them so this helps
us
like put that block of a model inside
our current production
pipeline yala thank you so much
welcome to tabula